talking about defense budget first of
all
ben wally says he's got enough money at
the moment from the chancellor and the
prime minister privately we're being
told he's saying something different how
does labour feel
i think it's very clear that ben wallace
and number 10 are very divided on this
issue we've been warning the government
for some time that there is a problem
just a year ago they published their
integrated review of foreign and defense
policy that was meant to set the
country's strategic security priorities
for the next
10 years and in that there was very
little reference to russia even though
we were already seeing russian
aggression on the increase and a growing
threat in our own backyard we said to
the government at the time it is a
mistake to reduce the size of the army
they've cut 10 000 troops out of our
armed forces they've reduced our army to
its smallest size in 300 years
and in the focus on china they forgot
about the problems in our own
neighborhood i think ben wallace is
right to get serious and start thinking
about how they're going to repair the
damage that they've done but the uk
shouldn't be in a situation where we've
done so much damage to our own security
that we're having to scrabble around to
try to work out how to repair it at this
late stage so spending more on defense
where would that money come from well i
mean that's that's the question at a
time of soaring inflation
low growth in the economy and a
government that has raised taxes on
working people the only major economy to
do that during an inflation crisis that
is the problem that the government has
created i think it's right to review
defense spending in light of russian
aggression i think it's right certainly
for the government to review its own
strategy in relation to that what i'd
really like to know from ben wallace and
i suspect he will be called in front of
mps in the coming days to explain this
announcement this morning is how the
government envisages they're going to
spend that money there is clearly a
split in government
with ben wallis saying we've got to
work more closely with partners we've
got to partner up through nato which we
fully and wholeheartedly support and liz
trust who is currently on tour um
smashing up the relationships on which
we're going to depend if we're going to
stand up to russian aggression
is it right that the money that we're
spending to try to defend ukraine or to
help ukraine defend itself should be
part of this budget
i think it's really important that we
take our national security seriously i
don't think this government has done so
in recent years
we shouldn't have been making harsh deep
cuts to our armed forces that left us
with the smallest standing army in 300
years we the first job of any government
is to protect its own citizens and i
think in light not just of growing
russian aggression on our doorstep but
also
the major challenge that is posed by the
rise and growing influence of china that
this has got to be a top priority for
any government
um i know you want to talk about special
needs education and the challenges as
far as funding that is concerned
well of course and you know i'm sitting
here today in harrogate i'm with local
government leaders from right across the
country labour conservative liberal
democrat all political parties and none
to talk about the challenges that they
face on the front line at the moment
trying to keep some of those vital
services going what we need to see is a
far more proactive approach from
ministers we need to see ministers like
michael gove getting on the front foot
sitting down with employers and unions
to try and work out how we feel huge
shortages in the workforce at the moment
we've got big problems in our schools
we've got problems in our hospitals
we've got problems
in our local government services as well
including social care which are
affecting families all over the country
we've got to keep these services running
we've got to pay people properly we've
got to square that circle
nobody has a magic wand nobody can do
this alone but in the end the only
solution to this is a proactive
government that plays its part that
partners with with our frontline workers
rather than treating them as enemies to
keep those services running and does the
job that they were elected to do which
is to level up this country and get the
economy firing on all cylinders growth
is the only way out of this conundrum
i'm afraid
do you support nicola sturgeon in her
attempt to seek clarification on whether
a second independence referendum would
be legal
no i think nicholas sturgeon has some
brass neck she and her friends in the
snp
were the ones who said that the
independence referendum was a
once-in-a-generation chance to settle
the question
and what she's done in the last 24 hours
is nothing to do with the interests of
scotland it's to do with the interests
of the smp she's launching an election
bid there are 700 000 people on waiting
lists in scotland for nhs treatment if i
were in charge in scotland i would be
looking very seriously at how to tackle
that crisis this is the thing that is
keeping families in melbourne awake at
night and she ought to be focusing on
that
um talk to me if you would please about
um the prime minister um he just seemed
to be um you know being quite um
prime ministerial should we say on the
world stage and it looks as though he's
doing a pretty good job um are we
forgetting all about party gate now
well look i think the problem that boris
johnson has
is that he's stepping into the global
arena at a time when people badly need
leadership from britain but after what
the prime minister himself has accepted
is a lost decade where britain has the
british government has not shown that
leadership even at the time when he's
standing with world leaders to present
what ought to be a united front against
russian aggression his own foreign
secretary is creating and stoking
division with our closest neighbours my
message to both liz trust and the
british government but also to the
french government and the european union
is we cannot afford to continue to be
divided in the face of the challenge in
the challenges that we all collectively
share we've got to find a solution so
that we can trade well so that we can
cooperate well and that surely has got
to include putting back on the table
something that the british government
took off the table a couple of years ago
which is how we er baking proper foreign
policy cooperation with our closest
neighbours in europe good to talk to you
as always thanks very much indeed for
joining us
thank you